[Musique]
tu parles d'un voyage aider dans la lune
il paraît qu'on sent dix fois plus léger
oui il ya les planètes ou la pesanteur
c'est pour la même ils ont peut-être
aussi qu il ya déploré qu la pesanteur
elle est à l'envers la pesée paroles en
l'air
drôle de planète yaka situeront
[Musique]
c'est marrant je crois pas au but
ils ont fait ce point louvre à ton avis
et le plafond c'est le plancher à quelle
heure il a eu 6 - 2 c'est pas mal comme
mobilier
non il est moins trois ans
des fruits temps là haut var on bat
[Musique]
laisse tomber là
une foule
[Musique]
et on dit qu'il ya des planètes ou que
l'homme sait c'est même pas un atome
tellement que les habitants ils sont
grands tiens toi tu es bien m'a lancé tu
serais o comme un pot de fleurs
[Musique]
imprimées continuer dit autre chose
quand il mais ça marche ça marque
ouais et plus fort
ben ouais ça va ça va là ça va je
dérange pas comment un vol de chair
fonds hors du charnier n'a pas articuler
avec une pensée lors nous aurons atteint
lugué
nous parlons
donne-nous hier un goûter mes qualités
et vous en faites trop de peine un mois
dur
partie vivre d'un raid héroïque et
brutale
j'ai rien à dire
il fallait en tirer le fanny petawawa
fabuleux métal que sifang ont mûri dans
les lointaines et les vents alizés un
dîner loews hôtel vous balancez pas ça
fait amateur
lombard mystérieux du monde occidental
et je vous croyais par kunitz a joué ya
plus de choix et il était parti trois
sets a fini j'étais content du tout est
bon chez de l'avant ni blanche car avant
il envoya le ballon scellant si tu vas
chez le boulanger tu me ramènes une
belle tête
il regardait monté en un ciel hinault et
ya pas de fantaisie valence écoute ya
pas de fantaisie tu vois la niche
il regarde une niche
et tu crois pas des croissants pour
germaine
il regarde et vous donnez un salut noël
aux puces tout mais qui se voulait
ranger
quand vous aurez fini le décor vous le
mettrez dans le petit cagibi la pure
nous expliquer pourquoi il y en a qui
pique
du fond de l'océan mais réflexion faite
je vais l'emmener moi même on sait
jamais dans ces cas là font des
spécialistes il dit
vous vous serez plus 38 vous serez plus
à l'aise pour vos mimiques un four
nations
et bien maintenant mesdames et messieurs
puisque ce soir nous rendons hommage à
la propreté de paris
voici un hommage à marseille voici donc
pour faire plaisir à marcel pagnol une
pièce d'edmond rostand cyrano de
bergerac à la manière de marcel pagnol
ancien homme qui prône une minute là
quelque chose que je voudrais te dire eh
oui fans de chine
au café la liste et alors que jacob
murayama la noce des canaris qui portera
le petit panier jeunes envisagent leur
amènera les caniches je suis phoenix
cela nous est cher
il portera le petit panier ou changer ça
pas nous
mais non tu l'as dit la chance aux
tuteurs lagarde
cyrano tu es un gramme les hommes et tu
deviens jo base pour toi c'est pas
possible et non tu as un grand dire que
la laine un grand groupe les a jamais
vus à une grande blair comme le groupe g
dit refuser la forme faire de la peine
que tu dises à petit et ça fait deux
semaines que j ai envie de te faire
d'apple et je me l'a glissé et tu le
redirai homme peut-il émotive là d'une
manière on réfléchit il faut que je le
remplis chis en tant que fer au top
avait la tête c'est difficile ça
c'est comme si tu disais le camembert
vous le voulez gagner ou qui s'abandonne
au report ombre cyrano kai eide
représentant spécial peu court au
bonhomme et tu auras plus trop votre
chance
si tu avais un peu plus de grain dans le
figuier serez vous dire par exemple le
nez de ce port au cirano il est gros
comme une automate de concours à
travaillant michel pas plus et il n'y
avait pas paniquer parce que tu es une
coucourde j'aurais pu dire encore sonné
quand il sent la mouche si le mistral
il a déjà dit ce monsieur rostain il a
déjà dit sam sur ce thème de quoi ils se
mêlent sans tabou y aurait plus encore
ce n'est qu'un exemple c'est
l'escadrille de marignane au grand
complet y compris les hélicoptères et ça
fait du bruit les hélicos terme hacker
ait pu passer mort ne passe pas je suis
mûr très aurait pu lire encore
descriptif
si un pic en vie qui en rend ce jeudi en
quarts ce média social facebook j'ai eu
la pénisule sénat péninsule ibérique
btcc la péninsule ibérique mais la
péninsule ibérique en la péninsule
ibérique mais c'est vital et vos
coordonnées
ap barré sur le vieux pont près du ferry
boîte aurait pu dire mais quand tu
regardes avait la longue vue
tu dois avoir l'impression d'avoir des
jumelles ont comme un sou et une petite
fille blonde de jemelle chez nîmes à
shopi tubulaire que ce serait trop long
à expliquer à la voilà ce que vous y
aider
si vous saviez dessous le projet sous la
casquette tu as compris et non j'ai rien
compris mais je dirai tout petit amour
je dirais aux gens ce cyrano
il n'a pas de plaire du tout mais voilà
qui ont en commun c'est du temps me
laisse très mal à l'autre tu n'as
parents comme un seul homme non dits ils
fêteront souris fait trop chaud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au premier quart à leur jeunesse est
sorti par l'influent mais sérieuse vous
présenter par ma bouche
pas vous
dans mes lèvres une mauvaise pièce de
théâtre maly free ait mal joué par des
mauvais comédien merci vous rappelle les
mauvais en anglais je m'abuse tu très
mauvais je voulais très mal présentés
merci beaucoup d'espacé pour la petite
machine
ça va me requinquer
[Applaudissements]
soc
voici tout seul au coin du feu
eh bien lisons mais quelle heure petit
bien-être comme hier les revers les
relais ça leur taper dessus
voilà les rangs sont encore en corse
aura 7 me disent déjà comme le temps
passe vite et est celle qui n'est pas
encore rentré mais j'entends la sonnette
du vestibule chantant la salette policy
petit somme 3 p tiens on frappe
entrer c'est fait
elle se sert des selles
bonjour s à ses toiles bon courage
jeudi l'iran à auxerre tenue tu vois
j'écrivais une mère et sa fille
accrochées aux championnats bougera pas
mais on te voilà blême
je suis madeleine glen eh bien eh bien
eh bien si tu te voyais ce principe ici
parce que je regardais truites et
saunier mais voyons dieu conrad
nous habitons le rez de chaussée y est
j'y croyais je me ronge
j'ai les six quotidiens mais cela
meirieu courage prend donc un siège
ainsi nous voici la sir à oui je vais
aller quérir une vieille bouteille qui
fais ce que tu veux de derrière les
fagots à bien la meilleure main bradley
lui dire ajoulots secret non courants
restent cois droite n'arrive qu'à la
mission est la revoici en date est la
rebâtir à atteindre c'est pas son
maintien
gut moi ce bon vieux porto
indirectement tu n'es pas une offre à
molette
tu as été bon jusqu'à août toi aussi
c'est vrai maintenant les taux sans cela
a fait tilt amusons celui ci aussi
m'esclaffer jeu
qu'est-ce qui joue bien ce type heures
mais recherché
il est élu comme l'état oui la femme a
joué deux fois mais non mais non
à propos de mac en costume je suis en
deuil mais non je ne suis pas en reste
que combattant vous
je suis pas en deuil de conrad ou plutôt
si je suis s'envole moralement arguments
bien en guerre mondiale qui chante bien
pierre joigneaux faire faire dans la
boue et steve constitue pauvre con rab
tu t'es trail y allons n'est pas l'air
plus bête que tu as l'air de nous deux
il y a un bel un v6 les bières si c'est
ou pas - ah j'aime pas l'entendre dire
qu'est-ce qui joue bien ce type le mans
mais dites nous quel est ton secours
courroux secours où j'étais petite ma
femme est à concubine mc entée villes
maghrébines pigiste combine
weepu rate ma femme tu la laisses
j'ai parlé la virgule n est pas toujours
trop me détend mais je suis plus en paix
mais la voici au pied du mur est au pied
du mur
j'ai une forte envie
te dire la mm20 et celles à un site on
perd en un seul jour ma femme et mon
meilleur ami un sans métro mais quelle
est cette douleur qui m'envahit les gens
du bar plus tard ciel je ne puis plus
bouger à le docteur me l'avait bien dit
que deux notions nouvelles
m'intéresserait
ac je souffre on bat du sine
on s'ennuie pas chez toi technique pour
toi deux mois une chaise cl ça
commençait à je ne jamais s'en souffert
oh oh que je suis
mais pas vu un petit boulot
et bien voici le voici dans mes meubles
du cap vert à boissy à six week-ends je
rêve de natation c'est bien cru l'a
rejoint
la donne et les heureux tous les deux je
le puis ch
mais cela n'est rien vieux conrad en ce
moment ça c'est moi quant à moi
j'entends ça l'est derrière jorge je ne
vous oublierai pas dans mon testament
ben non justement tout l'intérêt de
battiston châtie où le vent me suis dit
mais non mais non corrigée diminue mais
non arrêt 6b sûr mais non mais non
résident aussi fatick kolda pas revenus
j'admire jeu pas assurée tous les
garçons et maintenant qu'il est parti
et maintenant qu'il est parti mais que
dit il faut pourtant que jamais il faut
qu'on en finisse
vous ne prenez pas compte de leurs
pilotes mais moi petit peu chaude
ambiance à bayonne
bouger je pourrais me noyer dans la
pièce d'eau belle initiative qui courent
il s'est fendu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut cireur soir vie qu on peut causer
fanfou rubinstein avec le chômage
[Musique]
tu me cherches tu pensais je te chercher
un toit terminant à 5 min à feu doux
sans le bijou de l'écran or die abarth
feu d'artifice je suis pas pressé pour
te faire une grosse tête
ces galets tous les jours chez les mets
karine quiche aux lieux et aux délégués
un petit va dans ton genre c'était un
bergerac city il causait comme toi trop
de vigie porte des fleurs tous les on
l'a tous sont des chrysanthèmes il était
6h à qui m'impressionne pas si rare et
le patron il m'a dit comme ça si racj un
tocard et en les causes en sont à 1 10 y
sont card brige m'ont fait des tartines
il à 10 heures et s'est dit fier course
môme caramel et si je faisais une marche
ward d'occasions si je te paye un beau
matin chez panther sierra
j'ai mon lüscher conjointe avant demain
place à quoi c'est tout en piquant dans
un arbre dans le quartier d'abidjan
annoncé un peu comme si tu avais de
dollars derichebourg d'accord salle de
réunion sont mais voilà tient vraiment
chaud au concert
tu veux jouer les gros bras et puis t'as
rien de 6 h 21
nota les bretons et pour mon blaquart et
du directeur je vais lui refiler à vous
faire avancer sur les naseaux et cenpac
moon traité champions alors sur l'armée
du salut a refilé à un cierge l'enfant
de choeur ça aurait fait rire il y aura
une place mallet ya toujours de quoi se
marrer d'à-propos sierra j'ai vu
l'amoureux de sarran tu parles d'une
géométrie strange et l'idée laisse
tomber la souris ou c'est moi qui mène
ta voix charmeuse mauvais tu manges
convient dit qu'orange m envoyer au
frigidaire je le sens latin toyer la
distribution va y avoir droit à la vie
rurale c'est bien d'avancer maintenant
un bouge pas si grave ou je te couches
dans le muguet fleur de lin d'assigner
ton billet et [ __ ] peut-on faire part
d'une vraie carte postale règlements
locaux comme bourguignon sauter monsieur
sîrîn aux bergerac stephen de la banda
velpeau
8 avec la chine qui face à jean todt le
fils de ta mère en fait qu'en sierra
géant messieurs je te préviens je
rangeais devait grâce mon flux c'est
comme ça part tout seul ces trucs là
j'ai beaucoup ri syndicale feu donc
ouais ça fait certes héricois à motus
après 10 heures je travaille toujours au
silencieux qu'astérix tous à la
parfumerie marionnaud
c'est marrant tu commences à la bombe à
cacher les tétons noces d'or filmé par
deux fondateurs sur la grosse firme à
colon nous momboisse gros colon mon
intestin grêle et quand j'aurai fini de
causer un mais je pas tous mais à la fin
on voit rouge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me présente jus gréco
vous connaissez ma soeur
[Musique]
extrait de mon livre j'irai cracher sur
vos vestiaires c'est ma période glock
aussi un sketch show futuriste que
personne n'a jamais compris même pas
nous c'est la rencontre +0 de l'infini
je serai le zéro comme d'habitude et
jean marc thibault le comédia qui
souffrent
[Musique]
surnommé le recoudre et guerrière on
sait pas pourquoi le gain 6
et bien c'est récent
sera le 3ème mois
tulle 0 mais moi je suis là et je veux
mon chemin son frein sont peu son foin
garde pas nous est méritée moi rien d'un
monsieur normale mardi matin rajendra
écoute les hyperboles recherche sous
dialyse à thouars dans les paraboles je
connais une môme qui est ici en selle
après tu vas encore il parallélépipède
qui donne dans le carré de l'hypothénuse
pour mace volée que l'absurde d'abord on
n'est pas branché sur le même secteur
mais c'est vrai je n'ai pas mis quatre
cinquièmes d'asante imprudent sortir
sans aux hôtes
mais si t'as pas l'impression est par
conséquent pas encore tétouan a tu avais
la volière oui trente trois 33 33
tromper que fais-tu j'ai plus de mon
coeur qui pondent ce soir j'ai
transfusion amoureux obama songe en son
nom un diesel 400 chevaux 1 mais que le
but et en machines à laver peut dire
qu'on pourra d'une turbine et mon rêve
c'est une belle terre de classe mais
quitte à pistonner pour avoir sa belle
et ranger tu veux savourer ces petits 3
2% s'est dit toujours l'église pour
paver situe la ligne d'horizon de
longues seraient loin sommes dans l'un
des bus b2 puis ce2 à ces qualités là où
je serai importe des casse croûte à mon
nom puisque tout corps plongé dans
l'ombre reçoit bordeaux où une poussée
mais toi tu es l'archipel par 6 88 23
ans téléphonie mobile mais tu l aimes
d'amour à l'eau pas ainsi et alors mais
je la pluie mais comme tu dois souffrir
par les nuits sans lune surtout à
maubeuge
je me rapproche de troupes se confond à
ce fonds on sera bientôt plus qu'un coin
c'est jade a beau vivre mais pour
annoncer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors dites moi mon cher prisonniers
subsiste c'est commencer j'ai
l'impression que pour vous la guerre de
sécession à ccc si on ne fait lui répond
sa déçu mais dites moi maintenant
couzeix entre nos mains vous n'avez rien
à déclarer petit à petit et nous en
sommes et sudistes on avait été plus
nombreux
il est bien vous autres les nordistes
vous auriez bel et bien pris la porte
est-ce que vous respecterez y est ce que
vous venez de dire moi je m'en fous
pourquoi que j'aurais peut être répond
que si les sudistes
il avait déplu l'ombre et bien nos ordis
bon dieu il a révélé via auprès d'un fai
mais avez vous l'impression vous l'idsa
un ordi ce qu'elle leur dise n'importe
quel nordiste annonce abonde par vous
vous êtes caporal non alors vous êtes
serge et insurgents nordiste vous hors
de la cour de répéter votre petit il est
motivé
moi je la mène et puis j'ai dit mais
s'il s'y disent ils nous avaient dit
plus nombreux la pâtée
et bien je suis pas certain mais
bastarache tout ça ce fut la générale
quand cela arrange rien du tout et en
général 3 pour orgue et repetto combat
hier à je ne ferai pas des bêtises de
benjamin ce serait que le bât blesse
d'abord jean marc fait et dans la
conversation je ne dis pas de ministre
tant que six usb d'hypnose l'a pas fait
et bien sûr notre cinq minutes pour
changer de compte de silence hymne aux
gens font plus attention les gars je
vous avais fait suite à la victoire
nordiste qui a été élu un président très
familier avec ça y est c'est joe little
sauvage you chatouille
maintenant que vous êtes de l'autre un
compte en live et comment ça on l'a
échappé belle
si j'ai salopards de sudistes il avait
été plus nombreux nous autres les
nordistes on prend le bel et bien la
pente et me savine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre série aventure aux à l'ouest nous
sommes heureux et fiers de vous
présenter une superproduction
cinémascope et en technicolor
intitulé d'après le sonneur de tom mix
en français le retour de tom mix avec
dans le rôle principal
rodgers pierre the big star entourée les
célèbres acteurs rollmops tomato ketchup
les deux petites jumelles les soeurs
blue jays et sofia du plantain la
vedette qui pousse c'est une
superproduction de la métro goldwin
meyer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
conning broche my taylor is rich
bataille dr us lawe wayne callies
d'encadrants mesdames et messieurs
excusez mon camarade il ne sait pas que
vous ne parlez pas tous l'anglais alors
voici si vous le voulez bien maintenant
la version doublée en français de lens
automix le retour de tom mix c'est à
dire que nous allons donner une voix
françaises à célèbre américaine n'est ce
pas version post synchronisée comme on
dit au studio le gène villiers dans la
seine autobus 183 merci soir les gants
contre hambourg voir ouais je vous avais
dit que je reviendrais cinq ans jour
pour jour je suis fidèle au rendez-vous
pas en vrai nom l'âge la guerre ne sera
pas déterrer du côté des montagnes
rocheuses aigle noir m'a dit la vérité
celui qui habite jerry collins est ici
parmi vous ouais mais ta vie qui vaille
à plat de la bad or vous êtes banquiers
eux sarah entier les autres ouais c'est
lui qui a fait le coup a perdu un éperon
à sabots de gauche a été trahie weston
ta garde et abbott gauche et l'assassin
n'avait pas des concepts est un piège la
bouche pour bristol où je vais faire feu
tant pis pour toi
pas terrible ça on ne sait pas faire les
coups de feu
on dirait de l'eau chaude
justice est faite c'est pas ta bouche
pour reprendre le droit chemin liga
les liens de ces sessions à ccc si
pauvres n'ont pas la guerre de sécession
et philippe henry et nous devons nous
remettre au travail au le si content de
vous revoir sa mère connaissait trop
rire à tunis en bref vous flou si je me
sens tout timide
si vous avez fait quoi à jour est en
vous et vous est compté est ce que votre
père est décédé
il n'est pas mort vieux un parent resté
votre paix n'est décidé mais les trouver
sans perdre une minute pour sûr je vais
monter sur mon cheval et je ne dirai
qu'un bon
je
on monte sur mon choix les jeunes
puisque ce genre de gens ont chois
l'échelle dirait qu'un mot là mais mes
gars m'ont je peux pas lire là et je ne
dirai qu'un mot
[Musique]
[Rires]
ouah anne-marie je me suis je pense à
quelqu'un d'autre est gonflé quand je
vais le mettre en colère amélie hui tous
comme des lapins
l'auteur pourtant si fort
[Musique]
ah oui chérie que nous n'attendrons pas
l'avis de votre père à vous avez grossi
pour succès la choucroute oui nous
allons nous marier monde enjôleuse rossi
loges
nous allons nous marier prolonge par la
petite élise en place et devant toute la
famille réunie pour sûr nous serons unis
pour la vie oui vous mettrez votre belle
robe blanche et bobo chaussures à clous
et nous partirons tous les deux d'un pas
tranquille sur le chemin du bonheur
c'est fini oh pardon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hutaree mauvais moment c'est à l'homme
et à bastien tu as les clients arrivent
3 6 6 3 ces terres et moi je veux plus
prendre le métro les femmes ont changé
c'est pour croyable maintenant on se
croit tout permis
tentant de ces choses dans le métro mais
c'est vrai qu'elle est jeune et ouvrière
tout avec le vendeur nous est sûre les
poches bon ça passe encore est en voie
des bobards ce gars là pour passer la
nuit avec lui je leur ai bien tous mes
tickets de cantine bon ah c'est pas
méchant mais les pires c'est les
vieilles elles sont sûres noir une
vieille les vieilles elles tricotent
comme sa fille d'un seul coup elle te
balance une noyade [ __ ] dit non moi
je sais plus où m c'est vrai ils
mettront à dans le métro b franchement
inquiète tout le monde dans le métro
passe même du personnel l'autre jour dit
non j'étais en première j'avais pas mon
ticket ya une contrôleuse qui montre les
billets ouais tu sais confuse je les
ports madame raymonde tc la prison
qu'après quelle autorité saâles au
prestige de l'uniforme forcément alors
elle voyait que j'étais perdu tout en gt
rouge de confusion tu alors elle me
tapote la joue comme ça gentiment effet
bâti à rien a monté ça va s'arranger
effectivement il ya personne dans le
wagon ça s'est arrangé pour de francs 20
j'avais honte quand même c'est vrai mais
dans le métro les pires c'est les femmes
d'affaires voyez les femmes d'affaires
le tailleur strict pour aller pour aller
du chantier au bureau tu vois la
coiffure toute en ciment pour que ça
tienne toute la journée alors celle là
c'est les pires d'une main elles lisent
le point et valeurs actuelles puis de
l'autre haletant le point des valeurs
moi je dis non mais j'ai des bleus
partout
l'autre jour quand j'étais avec raymond
de colère et mon on avait fait du
shopping à propos on a trouvé des petits
pulls ravissant très joli ce nom c'est
vrai parce que raymond il connaît toutes
les bonnes adresses sa femme et à boca
par forcément ils reçoivent beaucoup ils
sortent beaucoup et obligés de
s'habiller à moindre j'étais là j'avais
tous mes paquets non mais c'est vrai on
achète trois fois rien ça fait tout de
suite du volume alors j'étais là je vais
réattaquer j'arrivais pas ouvrir la
porte
ayez une femme d'affaires c'est le genre
qu'adresse supérieur qui arrivent et qui
me fait je peux vous aider monsieur
moi tout de suite merci madame c'est
vrai j'aime pas qu'on m'aborde alors
après je me dis dans le fond pour une
fois que tu tombes sur une clé serviable
et puis toi qui l'avais pas dit alors la
main jallet tranquille
bon elle m'a raccompagné jusqu'à la
maison dit non elle voulait monter à
culoz ain en moi je dis non à cause de
mon père il
eh ben je vais retrouver tous les matins
devant ma porte
avec sa jaguar et son show feu son
chauffeur lucienne je peux pas la voir
et me regarde avec un petit air
méprisant je me demande pourquoi il me
prend pour un traînée elle prend pour
entraîner aussi pourquoi moi j'ai jamais
accepté un cadeau de sa patronne
bon si j'étais moins bête qu'un jeu
parade et fourrure des bijoux alors que
georgette madore s'appelle georges
heures par jour même chez le coiffeur
raymond shampouine il rire il faut dire
que lui les histoires de femmes ont pas
il vit avec gaston de manucure bon pour
en revenir à georgette l'autre jour j'ai
dit écoutez je rejette qu'est ce que
vous voulez elle me fait vous alors là
j'hésite projet si vous voulez épouse et
moi hachée crue cage il faut qu'ils
allaient bondir
et ben non on est resté très calme très
calme très calme est l a fait je vais
réfléchir
depuis j'attends mais si un jour j'ai la
bague au doigt jean callet qui va être
drôlement jaloux 1
c'est benoît walter et tous mes copains
du rugby est offert l'une de ses bêtes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le président directeur général
c'est au nom de tous mes camarades de
l'entreprise que je profite de
l'heureuse occasion de votre
anniversaire pour vous dire toute notre
admiration et toute notre reconnaissance
de tous mes camarades de l'entreprise
c'est pas tout à fait exact parce que ça
serait plutôt une initiative personnelle
oui parce que quand je leur ai dit
demain c'est l'anniversaire du patron
ils m'ont répondu le patron son
anniversaire il peut toujours pas ce que
c'était pas un enthousiasme
c'est comme pour le cadeau moi j'aurais
préféré une grande gerbe de roses plutôt
que seulement les collectes ne pas
donner ce qu'on escomptait et moi même
j'ai pas pu rajouter ce qui manquait vu
que je suis un peu gêné en ce moment
enfin ceci ne nous empêchera pas de vous
dire monsieur le président directeur
général toute notre admiration et toute
notre reconnaissance reconnaissance
d'abord pour votre carrière fulgurante
engagé ici même comme simple manoeuvre
vous ne tardez pas à être remarquée pour
votre ardeur au travail par la fille du
patron cas vous épousez neuf mois plus
tard
votre beau père conscient de votre
valeur vous confie bientôt la direction
de sa comptabilité
l'année suivante il est en faillite et
vous vous racheter l'entreprise
c'est alors qu'un nouvel amour vous
sollicite et vous épousez mademoiselle
gonds frolon ça qui voit naître dans les
établissements gonflons et du mousseux
qui seront bientôt les établissements du
mousseux tout court
après votre divorce puis survint la
guerre la mort dans l'âme vous fut
obligé de travailler pour l'occupant
mais dans un grand élan patriotique
vous ne reculait pas devant le sabotage
et vous livrer les pièces dans des
emballages de mauvaise qualité ce qui
occasionnera pour les allemands quelques
pertes de boulons et d'écrous qui ne
sont pas pour rien dans la victoire des
alliés à la libération
vous vous lancez dans la politique avec
un égal bonheur
sachant faire évoluer vos idées pour le
plus grand intérêt de votre entreprise
et aussi de la france puisque à chacun
de vos changements d'opinion correspond
à un accroissement notable des commandes
de l'état reconnaissance aussi pour un
patron qui a su en 1977 nous conserver
nos salaires de 1963 et ce malgré de
lourdes difficultés de trésorerie tels
que pertes au casino blocage en douane
d'un yacht de plaisance amende pour
fraude fiscale et cetera et cetera et
cetera reconnaissance encore pour tous
les avantages sociaux que vous nous avez
consentis je n'en veux pour preuve que
ce restaurant d'entreprise à la
nourriture chaude
est abondante et à la décoration
sipa pente mais où il est à regretter
qu'à la suite d'une compression de
personnel on nous ait demandé de faire
nous mêmes les achats la cuisine et la
vaisselle
ce qui forcément amené beaucoup de nos
camarades à manger chez eux et ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui même je me sens bien
seul dans cette grande salle
si pimpante mais comme j'ai eu l'honneur
de vous lire tout à l'heure j'ai un peu
généreux en ce moment il faudra
d'ailleurs que je vous en recause enfin
monsieur le président directeur général
je voudrais conclure et apporter à ce
concert de louanges
ma modeste participation personnelle en
vous clients bien fort bon anniversaire
papa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est difficile la langue
française vous trouvez pas c'est
difficile à d'abord c'est illogique
c'est complètement illogique
par exemple sienne c'est le féminin de
chiens et ben traîne ça n'est pas le
féminin de train allez comprendre
et pourtant si vous dites à un coureur
cycliste est à la traîne
il vaut réponse ne pas suivre le train
c'est complètement illogique c'est comme
seine seine qui n'est pas le féminin de
st et pourtant maintenant pour monter
sur scène pour montrer ses seins si si
si à six mois on me l'a pas encore
demandé
non mais je vous préviendrai offert une
occasion de revenir par me l'a pas
demandé mais si on me le demandait
qu'est ce que je répondrais je ne suis
pas sain ils vont faire une scène
annoncée difficile la langue française
installée essayé d'expliquer ça un
étranger
c'est un marin qui cherchent une
marraine déjà bon il fait des pieds et
des mains
il se démène mais comme il n'a pas de
belles ces efforts seront vains et en
voilà encore adlène j'écris comprendra
rien très tranchées surtout si c'est un
étranger du nord du nord de vervins où
il ya de la verveine
et des frites et moi par exemple je
connais une fille
quand on voit ses cheveux d'ébène tout
le monde fait vous êtes déjà venu vous
nom ne fait elle a un port de reine à
cause de sa chute de reins salle non
elle mange trop de pain en gros si moi
ça me fait de la peine
alors je dis si tu veux encore faire du
gain mais une gaine annonçait difficile
à l'enfance et c'est très difficile
allô allô allô allô subissait oui c'est
encore bois vous avez reconnu ma voix
bah oui je sais je vous téléphone
souvent je vous importune mais je suis
tellement utile à monsieur commissaire
ya plus d'un an maintenant que ma
fiancée a disparu et vous n'avez rien
retrouvé un même pas un petit morceau
oui je sais que je suis macabre mais qui
se voulait dans des moments pareils on
pense au pire et c'était une femme qui
cherchait à se mettre en quatre pour
faire plaisir ça pue donné l'idée à
quelqu'un mais oui je sais je n'aimerais
pas penser à ça mais vous comprenez je
le devais en faire ma moitié
enfin je veux dire on devait se marier
juste avant de disparaître
elle m'a donné une procuration sur tous
ses biens alors mettez vous à ma place
je ne sais pas comment la remercier et
moi qu'est ce que je vais faire de tout
cet argent maintenant oui bien sûr des
dons oui bien sûr monsieur le
commissaire des dons aux ordres de la
police
oui
oui bien sûr je pensais enfin vous
n'avez vraiment rien trouvé vous avez
cherché partout même pas j'suis pas
moins un petit en cendres mais oui je
n'aurais pas pensé à ça mais ça arrive
monsieur le commissaire joe jules ferry
ah bon vous vous pensez qu'elle est
partie avec un homme rôle dans le fond
ça me rassure un peu parce que la
dernière fois qu'on l'a vu elle prenait
le train c'est ça oui avec un homme
qu'on n'a pas pu identifier
radi dont on vraiment n'a pas pu
l'identifier wee cc votre conclusion
vous arrêtez l'anc est là dessus oui
écoutez je suis désolé monsieur le
commissaire je n'ai plus qu'à vous dire
merci et adieu succès chery bonne
nouvelle on va pouvoir se marier
ouais t'es content tu vas enfin appeler
madame landru
[Musique]
ou madame l'infirmière oui c'est moi qui
vous appelez oui il faudra que j'écrive
à ma femme
1 bah oui je vais encore avoir du mal
bon ça vous ennuierait pas d'écrire à ma
place je vous dictez merci ma chérie euh
bah oui je suis pour moderne c'est dans
l'hôpital que je t'écris pour te dire
que tout va très bien pour moi bien sûr
je ne serais pas auprès de toi pour le
15 ou mais je pense que d'ici noël
je serai remis de mes nombreuses
fractures quoi quand je suis sorti du
coma j'ai appris avec surprise que tu
n'étais jamais venu me voir et que tu
n'avais même pas demandé de mes
nouvelles études disent prêtes
je suis sûr que tu l'avais déjà oublié
ce qui m'était arrivé enfin par contre
quand l'inter note à téléphoner et que
tu lui a répondu il peut toujours crever
son minable
là je crois que tu exagères tu n'avais
pas le droit de parler comme ça surtout
devant un étranger je sais bien que nous
nous étions chamailler la veille que
j'avais eu le tort d'élever la voix
enfin pas tellement mais quand même
c'est pas beau de boue des points
d'exclamation l'assureur m'a écrit pour
me dire que j'étais responsable de
l'accident
vu que je n'étais pas en état de
conduire à cause des coups de marteau
que tu m'avais donné sur tu parles comme
si je n'en avais pas l'habitude
il est vrai que lui ne connais pas ton
caractère emporté points de suspension
le commissaire affirme que c'est toi qui
a saboté la direction de ma voiture
les voisins sont vus en train de scier
mon volant alors là je m'insurge
tu sais comme je tiens à mes affaires je
n'avais pas le droit de toucher à ma
voiture c'est une grande indélicatesses
si tout continue comme ça je finirai par
croire que tu ne m'aimes plus voilà c
est meme pas de formules de politesse
qu'est ce qu'il me vexer
[Applaudissements]
mercadier tu marconnet mouillart ça va
me souviens on était à la fac ensemble à
environ ça veut le plaisir de devoir tu
changes spot selon la chaque feuille je
prends l'avion je rencontre quelqu'un
que je connais aucun tu sais qui j'ai vu
la semaine dernière
blanchot et si lent chaud il était avec
nous en fac ya plein de cheveux une
grande barbe mais si blanc chaud on
l'appelait blanchot la nar show un grand
costaud il était toujours en tête dans
les manifs alors drôlement a droit un
pavé un flic un pavé roulement costaud
blanchot il change pas et il a plus de
cheveux il a plus de bars mais je change
pas ça il est content il épousé la fille
d'un magistrat et l'année prochaine il
espère être commissaire divisionnaire
enfin ça va il est content au fait tu
change pas non plus hein tu es toujours
ta belle gueule à à hautmont salon
qu'est ce que j'ai pu être au tu nous
piquer toutes les filles reprend puis
alors il en fallait un
quatre par jour
un vrai obsédé à bon as-tu peu plus au
bois tu fais ce programme ça soigne
ah non tu peux plus à cause de ton
métier c'est bizarre ce qu'est ce que tu
fais donc haute évêques balilo je m'en
serais pour douter c'est vrai que
maintenant pratiquement vous êtes
habillé comme nous et c'est vrai on voit
plus la différence
alors comme ça tu as eu la vocation ah
non c'était pour faire plaisir à sa mère
elle tenait beaucoup ta mère ah ben moi
non je change pas non plus oui ça va je
suis pas mécontent un dépôt n à ces
bruits écrivait des poèmes
tu sais je suis plus beaucoup le temps
d'écrire de la poésie on fera j'écris
quand même je suis journaliste
non pas littéraire non financiers bon eh
ben je suis bien content de t'avoir rue
p je suis content surtout de voir que
l'on change pas monsieur le président
messieurs et mesdames les jurés ma
plaidoirie sera très courte
non pas que je manque d'arguments pour
la défense de mon client
bien au contraire mais le temps qui nous
a été imparti dans cette audience a été
plus que largement dépassé je dirais
même dévoré par l'éloquence ô combien
copieuse et que je connais trop de
madame l'avocat général et le camp ce
moins copieuse dans un prétoire qu'au
téléphone croyez moi tout à l'heure je
ne tenterai pas d'user de mon charme
comme on l'a fait par ailleurs je ne
jetterai pas quant à moi de longs
regards langoureux à monsieur le
quatrième jurés qui ressemble à alain
delon comme n'a cessé de le faire
pendant tout ce procès madame l'avocat
général en sorte ici même ce début juin
tout à l'heure avec une cruauté
kim est hélas familière madame l'avocat
général vous a réclamé la tête de mon
client
sous prétexte que celui-ci avait
fracassé celle de sa femme avec un
chandelier louis saez et non pas louis
xiii comme aux le prétendre madame
l'avocat général qui n'a aucune
compétence en décoration vous verriez
notre appartement c'est absolument qui
te alors messieurs les jurés
celui ci n'aurait donc aucune
circonstance atténuante
et pourtant messieurs les jurés vous
êtes des hommes mais monsieur le
quatrième jurés vous êtes des hommes et
par conséquent des maris ne vous est il
jamais arrivé d'être torturé par votre
conjointe avec ses petites phrases
insidieuse du genre
madame lambert est resté bien longtemps
dans ton bureau ou bien encore tu as
dansé bien souvent avec madame mignon au
bal de la sous-préfecture maintenant
gens nous arrêtent madame l'avocat
général pour madame millions vous n'avez
jamais rien pu prouver
et au cours de ces tortures journalières
ces petites phrases empoisonné ne vous
ont-elles pas messieurs les jurés donné
l'envi dojo t à votre conjointe à votre
tortionnaires en jupon le premier objet
qui vous tombait sous la main
le malheur a voulu pour celui ci que ce
fut un lourd chandeliers d'argents pour
moi ça n'était qu'un code civil dieu
merci c'est moins meurtrier au je n'irai
pas jusqu'à prétendre que mon client est
l'image même de l'innocence oh non j'ai
même rarement vu dans un prétoire une
pareille tête d' assassin aussi
messieurs les jurés
si maintenant solennellement je vous
demande son acquittement pur et simple
croyez le ça n'est pas pour lui mais
pour moi pour que je retrouve ma dignité
d'homme pour la faire bisquer celle là
et si jamais par malheur mais ce que les
jurés ma voix et flore et ne parvient
pas à vous convaincre
si par malheur vous ne comprenez pas le
message insolite d'un homme aux abois
alors alors alors tu verras la maison
tient
[Applaudissements]
hamiti guide
bonjour c'est un ancien timide qui vous
parle vous êtes et année maudite cas
l'assurance quel aplomb
c'est pas possible que ce type là était
timide un jour est basse et j'étais
timide comme vous je les ai eus votre
regard fuyant aux épaules basses
j'étais ridicule mais aussi comme vous
je tremblais comme une feuille devant
les gens je ne sais pas m'exprimer je
parle à voix basse je suis sûr mais plus
maintenant car je suis guéri je me suis
soigné j'ai lu la méthode des
professeurs la folle et chazot de rennes
ille-et-vilaine un nom pour oser
demander le libre jusqu'à ce que je
m'aperçoive que mon libraire est encore
plus timide que bout il était tellement
timide cet homme qui n'osaient pas
rendre la monnaie
il faisait semblant d'oublier alors
comme moi je n'osais pas lui réclamer je
faisais semblant de ne rien qu'on a des
réactions curieuse quand on est timide
moi j'en étais arrivé à ce point que je
n'osais plus regardé personne en face
même pas moi je me voyais dans une glace
je rougis sais et je les tourner la tête
voyez comme c'est commode pour se raser
à l'hôpital ils l'ont dit à l'hôpital
ils m'ont dit on va finir par manquer
d'agra moselle alors j'ai lu la méthode
en question et je fais tous les
exercices
mais alors le plus difficile c'est le
dernier holding sas est épouvantable et
seulement attention si vous le faites
bien vous êtes sûrs d'être guérir
ils appellent ça le test de la gifle et
vous choisissez quelqu'un dans la rue ou
hasard quelqu'un que vous ne connaissez
pas qui par conséquent ne vous a rien
fait et pas vous
paul chifflet est pas faux le fait
remarquer comme ils disent dans le livre
il ya 90 % timide
vous n'avez donc pas neuf chances sur
dix pour qu'on vous la rampe belgique
moi j'avais un petit peu tricher parce
que depuis quelques temps dans mon
quartier j'avais remarqué un jeune
garçon et qui vous voyez y rougissait
ils baissent les yeux et rasait les murs
au je me suis dis toi mon bonhomme tu es
encore plus timide que moi tu le rapport
à l'état baigne lendemain je le croise
dans la rue papa de torgnoles et ben il
me les a pas rendu vous savez ce qui m'a
dit je ne savais pas que vous étiez au
courant
les gens disent n'importe quoi n'importe
quoi dans ces cas là quand j'ai raconté
ça à ma femme et à paris pour securion
apparu enfin moi ça y est je suis
derrière vous vous pouvez pas rester
comme ça ah non non non il faut faire
quelque chose
alors écoutez vous allez suivre mon
conseil vous allez commencer par
l'exercice du regard appuyé vous avoir
c'est très facile mais en plus de ça
c'est rigolo l'exercice derrière appuyé
imaginez que vous êtes en présence de de
quelqu'un qui vous impressionne je sais
pas moi votre professeur
votre chef de bureau à ministre
n'importe quoi bon vous ne lancez pas le
regarder en face dans ces cas là vous
savez ce qu'il faut regarder sa
braguette et oui mais oui il va se dire
il va se dire ça y est elle est ouvert
il va être gmail est alors plus trajet
n'est plus bon vous allez reprendre
contenance du gordel essayé entre vous
très rigolo
essayez entre vous les allégeances et
très fin c'est très amusant
nous le verrons au fur à mesure que lui
bah pas perdre contenance
vous savez à priver de certaines
assurances bientôt cesser 2 de bégayer
et vous serez débarrasser définitivement
de cette envie irrésistible que vous
avez depuis
le cas
non
italy's franchement non je n'aurais pas
non à nombreux alors oui oui deux non
alors oui oui si l'ancien jean pardon
cher monsieur mes lauriers roses
s'il est à moi c'est la première fois
que je dors sur le palier alors je ne
suis pas au courant des habitudes un
monsieur nous le katana willich à la vie
de cet immeuble que depuis deux jours
changé mais enchantés monsieur en
chantier et si vous amène un différend
avec ma femme
enfin c'est pareil nous aussi alors
monsieur je vous fais juge jallet for me
coucher je les trouve complètement au
travers du lit non mais vous vous rendez
compte
mais quel culot la colère m'a pris la
moutarde me monte au nez ou s'avérer
monter la moutarde au nez mais c'est pas
la place pour la moutarde mon coach j'ai
hurlé à serrer les piques et j'ai fait
alors ça vous avez bien fait je fais pas
ça y'a pas envoyé dire quelle autorité
[Musique]
non mais dis donc deux voies non j'ai
pas eu tant les soit peu de places toit
ou 105 1 je vais coucher sur le palier
trash les diggers l'autorité le jeu ça
n'a pas traîné elle s'élevait est allé
se coucher sur un divan noël s'est levée
elle m'a poussée sur le palier et s'est
alors lâché ricaner et je l'insulté
grosses bêtes
quelle autorité monsieur à la fouillade
approche de son peignoir à la tire et
son mouchoir elle a pleuré à noël a tiré
ses clés la ferme et la feria c'est vous
monsieur coucher soit sur le palier et
tous les vendredis monsieur le jeudi
souvent le mercredi parfois le mardi
c'est rare mais jamais le lundi pourquoi
l'ana chez sa mère et le faux gras dits
particulièrement oui j'ai un banquet à
l'amicale des anciens jeunes
alors si je range après 11 heures je ne
rentre pas assez ça une ferme car j'ai
pris une valise je me demande mon
oreiller mon pyjama de bouche bée je me
déshabille dans l'ascenseur et je me
couche directement sur le palier à
johnson même pas avant elle le sait que
je suis là non car je me manifeste pas
beau je l'inciterai lui qu'à l'autorité
et pourrait me supplier de rentrée du
jeune andré attendait peau telle qu elle
supplie france a fait 15 ans qu'il
supplie plus monsieur rabat par contre
la mienne tout à l'heure à 8 heures du
matin vous allez la voir elle va bien
ouvrir sa porte à la boutique méga de
rentrée non non non non elle va me dire
de lui faire son petit déjeuner s'il
vous qu'il baisse de 6 tous les matins
je le fais que un c'est pour l'humour
même jour mon inventaire annuel et
couchez vous êtes de mort ou la dominer
elle est vexé vous savez on l'a une
trouve plus ses mots elle me parle par
monosyllabes elle vous fait kpc lettreur
miel miel
qu'est ce que vous répondez à sa manche
n'est ce pas un peu amer monsieur les
femmes pour les dresser pour la grèce
enzo moi j'ai triché l'agneau enfin
j'aiderai sinon la vallée dressé oui on
peut dire ça c'est de rester tout seul
on le poids de soba un faubourg joui
regarder la télévision et sur un bon
sujet
j'arrive j'avais fait les connaisseuses
étant encore en charentaises j'avais mon
cabas montcabrier mon caddie j'arrive
année par félicite essence tourne elle
ne fait souche est vulgaire qui veut
dire ta bouche bb os
je répète ma foi dont jouit le nom
serait moindre amplement son geste
obscène à wii sports wii mais elle
ajoute pouilles
pout pout pout pout y avoue à son époux
y à 100 à son époux le stratège nous et
la bête humaine oui j'ai foncé l'office
zola la fin j'ai a capella non vous
n'avez pas dire ça aux quelle horreur
l'attendait là là ce nom là la bête
débile tablions oblige j'ai rien lui un
à la fois moi je le fais pour la
vaisselle ah ça non je fais pour la
vaisselle sam abîme les mains et après
je ne peux plus coudre
pas facile et c'est pas cool hein non on
ne sait pas mettre le couvert mais par
contre la cuisine alors ça la cuisine
elle l'a fait vraiment très mal à tous
mes amis me le dit c'est toi c'est
dégueulasse je n'irai pas eh ben on fait
la cuisine elle à son salon moi j'ai ma
guise
ah oui à la sauce à lens au piano son
chien tout ça et son fils au d'un nom
moi j'ai ma cuisine est entré une fois
elle m'a fait un chantier encore chaud
et ça me retard pour ma lessive à
m'aimer mais ça les fans ne veulent pas
le comprendre
nous on travaille toute la semaine on a
clos dimanche pour l'aller vous
connaissez mon bilan je me sens je le
dis non je me levais le matin jean
dujardin hulk ou leurs rivaux j'ai le
gazon l'après midi monsieur je fais ma
lessive les couleurs d'un côté le blanc
de l'autre après je suis du bois elle
vous fait le soir
messier bah ouais mais ça les femmes se
battent la vienne avant d'être mariée
elle travaille à mal le travail même
emmanuel travailler ma femme elle était
mannequin
ah bon chez balmain chez courrèges
sheholli da à huy à la santé une
personne qui a un certain physique pour
sa mise charcuterie oui et 13
appétissant à c'est une femme qui n'a
jamais ouvert une porte avec sa main la
toile je les croisais dans l'escalier
voulait pas pu la croiser ah bon elle
est incroyable
mais c'est pourtant vrai j'ai dû
redescendre deux états a lancé des
pétards lancés tels la ville du moule à
l'essai petites socquettes et nous c'est
cette personne qui porte son collier
horizontalement
c'est la seule femme au monde qui peut
compter ses perles en argent 1 et ce
qu'il a fait c'est la robe maxi pourquoi
on dirait une course en sac l'accord
n'en voyez vous la mienne at elle
ensuite toute autre branche de
l'industrie
elle était et ses yeux ses draps ans
c'est très rare était chez peugeot au
nom j'ai audigé nous avons nous pas du
tout loucher chocottes
la prothèse dentaire au lit dans wii
elle présente les modèles elle a un très
très bon physique pour samassa alors à
aller de l'avant
sacré calibre de pardon jeudi elle
s'appelle jeanine oui il s'appelle la
nina
ces chars et vous voilà tel concours à
ce charmant rock ou non vilain cocoyes
vilain qu'on vous a déjà perdu tous nos
cours du tout non non elle l'appelle
coco parce que je suis colonel de génie
oh non pas de juni de carrière et vous
je suis pdg monsieur pardon je fais des
gibbons parvenez moi je n'avais pas
entendu tout l'est m
catégorie g et j'ai dix usines
oui j'ai d'illizi et g20 secrétaire et
demain en arrivant au bureau
si l'une s'est permis un petit pouce à
la largue av oui mais je sais pourquoi
ya pas longtemps
d'abord allé voir sur le palier si je
suis à l'autre en vigueur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]